أنت تعرف أن أي أم هي كل شيء بدءًا من
المدرب الرئيسي لفريق كرة القدم إلى المدير
التنفيذي في حفلة إلى منسق الموسيقى في نادٍ ما ،
وأنا بالطبع أستخدم هذا كاستعارة ، لذا
فأنا على متن طائرة وفي تكساس
أحصل على هذا  مكالمة هاتفية من هذين
الزوجين تشبهان في الأساس إلقاء البرياني
على بعضهما البعض شيء يجب أن أصبح
نوعًا من القسيس لتهدئة الناس
هناك هذه السيدة التي تجلس بجواري
هذه المرأة البيضاء ونزلت من الطائرة
وما زلت على الهاتف  مع هذين
الزوجين ، السيدة تتبعني كما تعلم ، وأنا أشكرك ،
ها نحن نذهب ، ثم
تأتي إلي ولديها
صليب جميل كبير حقًا وهي مثلكم
تعلمون أنني أريد فقط أن أشكركم على قيامكم
بعمل يسوع المسيح هكذا  قلت لها أنك
تعلم أنني حقًا أقدر
حقًا أنه صليب جميل حقًا أعتقد
أنه يجب عليك الاحتفاظ به لأنني مسلمة ،
لذلك قالت تعابير وجهها هناك
إنني مسلمة ، لقد كانت نوعًا ما
وكأنه ليس من الممكن كيف يمكنك ذلك
تعرف ثم شرحت لها كما
تعلم  المسلمون ليسوا متجانسين ، فنحن نأتي
من خلفيات مختلفة جدًا ،
والبعض منا متدينون ، وبعضنا يتعافى
مع الإفلات من العقاب ،
أنت تعلم أننا في مكان ما في المنتصف
يوجد مخطط فين لأشخاص مثلي